hello and welcome to simplys YouTube
channel today we will be doing Hands-On
lab demo on color recognition system
using Python and ml in this we will be
using open CV and some python libraries
like pandas and umpire before moving on
to the handson if you want to become an
AI expert and gain handsome salary
packages look at wide range of AIML
courses by simply run in collaboration
with top universities across the Globe
by enrolling in any of these
certification program you will gain
expertise in skills like generative AI
prompt engineering chat jity explainable
AI machine learning algorithms
supervised and unsupervised learning
model training and optimization and
there is much more on the list with
hands-on experience in tools like chat
GPT Dal python open CV and tens flow you
will be catch the eye of top recruiters
so what are you waiting for hurry up and
enroll now year of experience is
preferred to enroll in these courses
find the course Link in the description
box below so without any further Ado
let's get started so now let's embark on
a python journey together to explore
color recognition commonly referred to
as a color detection our goal is to
build a simple application that can
identify color within an image
additionally our program will provide us
with the RGB values of the detected
colors adding a helpful touch to the
process so let's change the name first
here I will write
color
recognition
application okay let's rename it first
so first we will import some libraries
some major libraries like
import
CV2 okay I will be small import CV2 then
numai as NP after that one more Library
import pandas s PD so let's run it so
open CV is a port open source library
for computer vision and machine learning
return return in C++ with python
bindings it helps developers handle
tasks like image processing object
detection and pH recognition through a
rich set of function and
algorithm talking about numpy numpy a
fundamental library for numerical
operation in Python it's like the Swiss
Army of knife for mathematical
operations especially when dealing with
arrays and matrices talking about pandas
panda is the data Wrangler of python
it's your go-to tool for handling and
analyzing structure data with its data
frame magic you can slice Dice and
manipulate data effortlessly moving
forward let's import our image first for
that we will be writing here IMG you can
write any name IMG equals to
CV2 do IM read your image name my image
name is CC do
jpg okay let's run it so here CV2 do
read it's read an image file and
converts it into numpy array which you
can then manipulate using open CV's
magical powers so when you are diving
into color recognition this function
help you grab the image and get ready
for the real show so moving forward we
will import color CSV file first we need
to train our model to identify colors to
do this we need data that includes name
of colors and values corresponding those
colors so here I have one CSV files of
the all the colors present so here since
most colors can be set using red green
and blue this is why we will be using
RGB format these are the RGB format
these three rows D E and F this is why
we will be using the RGB format as the
data points so this is a ready CSV file
with around th000 color names and RGB
values and you can download this color
CSV file from the description box below
okay so here let's uh import that file
so first I will like to give some index
values index equals
to that here I will write
color
comma color
name then
comma then hex
value comma
r g and
B B because as you can see in this file
there is no uh heading column name okay
so here I'm giving the column name using
index so now let's import our CSV file
CSV equals to PD do read _
CSV then colors.
CSV okay comma names equals to
index then header equals to
none so here pd. read CSV is used to
read the particular CSV file any CSV
file and this names equal to index The
Heading names it will give the column
names to all the values so now let's run
it first so no error is coming so now as
our next step we will Define two
function for our programs to work
properly we need some Global variables
so you will know how Global variables
can be useful when working with
functions so but before that let's set
click and RGB values equals to zero Okay
click means when you will click on a
particular image then we will make it to
true r letter so first I will write here
click equals to
false okay then r = g = to B = to then X
position okay = to Y positionals to zero
okay let me make it
better that's looking good okay so
so now let's make function let's create
function so I will write
DF DF is used to uh you know Define the
function in Python so DF uh
recognize
color okay space is missing okay
recognize color then R comma G comma P
colors okay go on so here I will write
minimum equals to
10,000 then here I will run one
Loop
for I
in range and length of
CSV then I will write here D equals to
ABS then R
minus int of
CSV do location
l
l i comma then r
value
okay then here I will write plus then
again abstract value
ABS G minus
int
CSV do
looc I comma G
then again plus
ABS B
minus sorry ah right B minus uh then I
will write here
int
CSV do
loc then I
comma
B okay then here I will set if D is
greater than equal
to
minimum
than
minimum equals to
D okay then here C name equals to
CSV
looc I comma that color name will be
displayed
color
name then
turn C name color name okay let's run it
okay it's working properly so this ABS
you can see here ABS function so this
ABS function Returns the absolute value
of the given number if the number is a
complex number uh so this ABS returns
its magnitude and this lo you can see
here this
Lo so Lo property of the data frame
object allows the return of specified
rows and or you can say the columns from
the data frame okay so this particular
function this recognizing color this
particular function will be called when
you will double click on the area of the
image it will return the name of the
color and the RGB values of for that
particular
color so moving forward let's create
Mouse click
function okay so here I will be writing
DF
space
Mouse
click event will be there X
comma y comma
Flags comma
parameters okay so here if
event go equals to
CV2
dot
event L button left
button double
click okay then what then
Global B comma G comma R comma
Exposition comma y position comma
click
okay okay let me give some spaces to
look
better
yeah then here I will make this now
click equals to
true so X position equals to X X then y
position = to Y then B comma g r = to
IMG y
x then Bal to int
B then g equals
to
int
G then R equals to in
okay let me give one space here
also yeah so let me run it first there
will be no error yeah no error seems
good so this mouse click function is a
helper function which is a part of our
program which will help in the process
of double click when we will clicking on
the particular image double clicking so
it will return the various uh values
like name of the color and the RGB
values so now let's make the process
using computer vision open CV our next
step will be like this okay let me give
some spaces to for the better visual so
what we will be doing in this step we
will open the image in a new window
using the open CV methods and on that
window we will be use the function we
defined earlier like these two function
recognize color and the mouse click
function Okay so this application is so
simple that it Returns the name of the
color and the color values when you will
double click on a certain area of a
image okay at the end we will see how
this is working so let's code it fast
and see the amazing results so here I
will be writing uh
CV2 dot
named
window like uh you can say the bar open
so here uh you can write give the any
name I am giving the color
[Music]
recognition application
application
okay and after that CV2 do set
mouse
mouse call back these all are the uh you
know inbu function of CV2 open CV so
here I will write same
color
recognition
application oh my
bad application comma Mouse
click okay here I will write V one true
one means
true okay so here I will write CV2
dot I am
show that this
color
recognition
application comma IMG using this IM show
you can you will see the your image
which you have uploaded which we have
uploaded here this cc.jpg so using I'm
show we can display our image using open
CV if if clicked this is the main point
if clicked then CV2 dot
rectangle then image will become then
starting point of the image okay let me
get the comma here then starting point
of the image 20 by
20 then end
points 7 50 comma
okay
comma then color BGR values or RGB
values B comma G comma
R comma the thickness uh minus one y
minus one minus1 fills the entire
rectangle that is why I'm writing minus
one here okay so now let's uh creating
the text string to display the color
name and the RBG RGB values so here I
will write the text text equals
to
recognize
color R comma G comma
B
plus R equals
to plus the string of R the value of R
you can say and why I'm writing R here
because it will be display there like a
particular color name then r equals to
this value g equals to this value and b
equals to this
value
okay these are the some basic python
string
functions equals
to plus Str G okay then one is remaining
the B is remaining
plus Bal
to St Str
B string St
strb so now moving forward we will uh
use the function put text so what put
text put text will do it will uh put the
text from a particular value okay from
the CSV file so here I will write the
CV2 do put
text text then image IMG comma text
comma then the starting point
comma
font okay font I'm putting the two only
and the font scale will be
0.8 and then comma then uh color
thickness we are writing so I will give
the 225 255 and 255
then comma here two is thickness okay
then line type will be I will write CV2
dot
line
a
okay then for every light colors we will
be display the text in the black color
okay because it won't be visible so here
I will write if
r + G + B is greater than equals to
600 then CV2 dot put
text the same let me copy from
here and here I will do 0 0 0 0 comma 0
comma 0 got it the rest is same the
color color thickness font font scale
everything is
same okay here now
click equals to
false
okay so now what we will do if CV2
dot weight
key
20 and
0x FF equal equal
to
27 then
Breck
okay the rest is CV2
dot
destroy
all destroy all
windows so what will happen if I want to
break the loop so if the user hits
escape button Escape key so it will
destroy the window the particular window
you know the image
window okay so now let's run
it so now as you can see if um it's the
color name is piggy ping then R values
is the G values and B values if I will
double click on any color on any area of
this particular image you can upload any
kind of image your image any kind of
sort of image so this is see the name of
color is banana yellow r = g = b and
this colors are coming from that CSV
file that we have uploaded earlier in
this project so this is how this color
detection works you can click anywhere
and it will give the color Smokey black
and that's electric blue so I hope you
like this video on how you can create
color recognition application with
python and open CV and now you can have
a good idea of how you can Implement
computer vision in real world task so
feel free to ask your valuable question
in the comment section below so thank
you for watching stay safe and keep
learning with simply learn staying ahead
in your career requires continuous
learning and upscaling whether you're a
student aiming to learn today's top
skills or a working professional looking
to advance your career we've got you
covered explore our impressive catalog
of certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here